wenn ich mir die Reaktionen aus der
Regierungskoalition anschaue der eine
FDP-Abgeordnete spricht von einer
Atombombe für unser Land der andere von
einem
heizungsverbotsgesetz dann zeigt es doch
im Grunde genommen schon wie
handwerklich schlecht die
Bundesregierung davor geht und wenn ich
mir das Gebäude Energiegesetz anschaue
dann ist es eben ein Gesetz das zutiefst
den Grünen Geist der bevormundungs der
Verbotspolitik atmet man muss sich das
einmal vorstellen den Menschen wird
vorgeschrieben wie sie zu heizen haben
und zwar nicht in einiger Zeit sondern
ab dem 1 Januar 2004 und 20 und es führt
egal welchen Weg sie nehmen am Ende
immer zur Wärmepumpe weil ganz
offensichtlich im
Bundeswirtschaftsministeriums Strom
Fetischisten sitzen